remember the last time you had
butterflies in your stomach
or felt your heart leap those abstract
feelings
have to do with a real physical nerve
the vagus nerve
it connects the brain to what are known
as the body's visceral organs the heart
larynx intestines and more
while our sight and other senses connect
us to the outside world
the vagus nerve and other nerves and
hormones tell the brain what's happening
inside our bodies scientists estimate
that more than a hundred thousand nerve
fibers make up the system
forming a two-way superhighway of
constant information
a full belly needing to cough and a
racing heart are just some of the things
the vegas communicates
it also transmits signals from the brain
to the viscera to jumpstart digestion
or slow the heart it's hard to trace the
vagus nerve's thin twisting branches
through the body
techniques used to map brain connections
in animals don't work as well in the
body
as they do in the brain but new
techniques are helping scientists follow
its wandering path
they hint that the vagus nerves realm
may stretch farther than scientists
realized
including into areas of the brain
responsible for memory
and emotion one method uses viruses to
probe the vagus nerve's network
to infect its host the rabies virus hops
from neuron to neuron
traveling all the way into the brain rat
studies have employed genetically
modified glowing viruses
that trace the network's path they've
revealed a vast
mind-body neural web scientists use this
method to discover a connection between
the stomach
and an area of the brain thought to
regulate emotions
another study honed in on a pathway
between the rat's stomach and
hippocampus
a brain region involved in memory after
severing the vagus nerve along this
track
the rats could no longer form some kinds
of memories
with these new maps researchers are
exploring treatments
involving the vagus nerve for many
conditions from inflammatory diseases
such as crohn's
and rheumatoid arthritis to alzheimer's
and heart failure
there are already implants approved by
the fda to treat epilepsy and depression
scientists are also testing a less
invasive device called
tavns since part of the vagus nerve
connects to the ear
researchers are trying to stimulate it
with an earbud-like device that
transmits electrical signals
along the nerve there are more than 100
clinical trials testing tavns
for conditions ranging from ptsd to
parkinson's disease
time will tell if vagus nerve research
will change lives
at the very least it's lent new meaning
to the phrase
gut feeling
[Music]
you